[Musik]
ein heute spezial zu dem anschlag in
hanau guten tag liebe zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer die tödlichen schüsse in hanau
am gestrigen abend mit insgesamt elf
toten sorgen bundesweit für bestürzung
ein 43 jähriger deutscher hat an drei
verschiedenen orten der hessischen stadt
zehn menschen erschossen und dann sich
selbst getötet
irgend eines möglichen rechtsextremem
hintergrund hat der generalbundesanwalt
die ermittlungen übernommen
hanau trauert an einem der tatorte legen
sie blumen nieder
hier wurden mehrere menschen in der
nacht erschossen die anwohner sind
erschüttert man kennt sich hier mein
enkelsohn hat der die schüsse gehört
weil mir wurde dort in den häusern und
da ist er hin gerannt und habe keine
polizei noch nicht dann krank war und da
dennoch sehen dass unsere freunde alle
tod von womit ganz alltäglich am chaos
war eingekauft haben wirklich das ist
einfach schrecklich dass die stadt ist
heute mit der nachrichtenagentur afp
gestern nacht gegen 22 uhr im zentrum am
heumarkt schießt ein mann in der shisha
bar mit neid um sich und tötet wir
menschen das video eines anwohners zeigt
bilder wenige minuten nach der tat da
war der täter offenbar schon
weitergefahren in richtung westen zum
kurt schumacher platz in kesselstadt er
betritt dort einen kiosk und schießt
wieder um sich fünf menschen sterben
hier den kioskbesitzer bot sich ein bild
des schreckens sein abgesehen fünf sechs
leute liegen auf dem boden
zwar hinter der tg 2 also alles tot
ein blutbad war mein neffe batterien ein
mitarbeiter alles tut der attentäter
fährt dann weiter zu seiner wohnung in
der nähe
die polizei nimmt die spur auf und
findet nachdem sie die tür aufbricht
zwei leichen die des mutmaßlichen täters
und die seiner mutter
bald wird auch offiziell bestätigt dass
es sich um ein attentat mit
rechtsextremistischem hintergrund
handeln könne
auf einem video im netz ist laut
sicherheitskreisen der täter tobias r zu
sehen die generalbundesanwaltschaft
zieht die ermittlungen an
auf der homepage des mutmaßlichen täters
hatte er videobotschaften und eine art
manifest eingestellt die neben wirren
gedanken und abstrusen
verschwörungstheorien aber eine zutiefst
rassistische gesinnung aufweisen
die opfer haben alle einen
migrationshintergrund
das muss ich sagen macht mir wirklich
sorgen das gesellschaftliche politische
klima klima in deutschland ist sehr
beängstigend und ich fühle mich an ich
als deutsche mit meiner migrations
biografie nicht wirklich wohl
und so hat das attentat über hanau
hinaus eine weitere
gesellschaftspolitische dimension
wir gehen nach karlsruhe zu christoph
schneider vor einer stunde hat sich der
generalbundesanwalt geäußert in welche
richtung gehen die ermittlungen der
generalbundesanwalt peter frank ist
persönlich vor die presse getreten das
muss man sich auch vorstellen
normalerweise erledigen das immer
pressesprecher in dem fall ist er
persönlich vor die presse getreten und
hat noch mal erklärt dass er den fall
auch wegen der besonderen bedeutung an
sich gezogen hat die wohnung von tobias
r ist heute morgen von einem
sondereinsatzkommando durchsucht worden
das hat er in diesem rahmen auch gesagt
und es haben sich indizien ergeben für
einen rassistischen hintergrund
strafrechtlich ist bislang der tobias r
nicht in erscheinung getreten
und jetzt ist es sache der weiteren
ermittlungen das umfeld mehr
herauszubekommen handelt es sich
wirklich um einen einzeltäter bislang
sieht es so aus aber das müssen weitere
ermittlungen ergeben
und das wird jetzt passieren durch
umfassende auswertung von spuren
kriminaltechnische untersuchungen werden
durchgeführt und damit hat der
generalbundesanwalt sowohl das
bundeskriminalamt in wiesbaden als auch
das landeskriminalamt hessen beauftragt
offenbar war der täter bei den behörden
bisher nicht aufgefallen
was weiß man über den 43-jährigen
in der pressekonferenz hat
generalbundesanwalt frank deutlich
gemacht dass es ein bekennervideo und
bekennerschreiben und ein video gibt und
das wird jetzt umfassend untersucht und
da werden sich möglicherweise weitere
anhaltspunkte dazu geben ob er
einzeltäter ist oder ob es
möglicherweise ein hintergrund gibt aber
das werden die weiteren ermittlungen
ergeben
vielen dank für ihre einschätzungen
christoph schneider nach karlsruhe eine
mutmaßlich rechtsextremistische
gewalttat in deutschland bundespräsident
steinmeier sprach den angehörigen der
opfer seine anteilnahme aus
bundeskanzlerin merkel erklärte vor dem
hintergrund der tat
rassismus ist ein gift matthias pelz hat
die reaktionen zusammen gefasst am
morgen schweigeminute im hessischen
landtag ein furchtbares verbrechen das
uns schockiert und sprachlos macht und
vor allen dingen unendlich traurig wie
man schon in hessen denken heute alle an
diejenigen die in hanau opfer geworden
sind sondern die angehörigen und dieses
mitgefühl möge ihnen in ihrer sehr
schwierigen stunde ein trost für die
bundesregierung äußerte zuerst
regierungssprecher steffen seibert per
twitter seine tiefe anteilnahme und
heute vormittag dann auch zahlreiche
spitzenpolitiker
die kanzlerin machte den anfang der
tiefe schmerz über den gewaltsamen tod
so vieler mitbürger denen die menschen
in hanau hält empfinden den empfinde ich
und den empfinden menschen in ganz
deutschland rassismus ist ein gift der
hass ist ein gift und dieses gift
existiert in unserer gesellschaft und es
ist schuld an schon viel zu vielen
verbrechen
wir stellen uns denen die versuchen in
deutschland zu spalten mit aller kraft
und entschlossenheit entgegen
es ist wichtig und das ist mir
persönlich ein anliegen dass wir ein
schnelles signal auch der solidarität
des zusammenstehen aller demokraten dass
wir dieses signal setzen in zeiten in
denen der rechtsextreme terror in
deutschland stärker wird heute
sollte das mitgefühl und die aufklärung
im zentrum stehen wir dürfen uns nicht
an solche taten gewöhnen und dann muss
die konsequente verfolgung und die
prävention einer solcher taten des
rechtsextremismus des rassismus
unbedingte priorität allen politischen
handelns sein
diese tat richtet sie sich aber in
wahrheit gegen uns alle denn sie stellt
ihn versucht da unsere gesellschaft
insgesamt zu verängstigen unsere
gesellschaft insgesamt gegeneinander
auszuspielen und das darf solchen
terroristen nicht gelingen und auch die
afg hat sich schriftlich über die
abscheulichen verbrechen in hanau
fassungslos und erschüttert gezeigt und
den opfern ihr mitgefühl ausgesprochen
zum gedenken wurde heute abend zu einer
mahnwache am brandenburger tor
aufgerufen
wir gehen jetzt zu dem ort an dem sich
gestern die anschläge ereignet haben
peter wagner ist für uns in hanau was
ist bisher über die opfer bekannt noch
nicht allzu viel was wir wissen ist dass
vier der todesopfer kurdischstämmige
sind aus hanau stammen ja auch in den
vereinen organisiert waren
man weiß außerdem das wohl eines der
mordopfer
eine schwangere frau war aber weitere
details hat die polizei bisher noch
nicht bekannt gegeben
es sind vor allem jüngere menschen die
in diesen beiden sicher
shisha bars ihren abend verbracht haben
sich unterhalten haben
und dann von diesem schrecklichen
verbrechen von diesem mörder überrascht
und umgebracht wurden bundesminister
seehofer hat den anschlagsort besucht
wie hat er sich geäußert
ja er war von einer knappen stunde hier
hinter mir hat einen kranz niedergelegt
zusammen mit der justizministerin
zusammen mit nahezu den kompletten
hessischen kabinett seehofer hat
zweierlei gesagt er hat zum einen was
eigentlich auch eine
selbstverständlichkeit ist
trauerbeflaggung für alle öffentlichen
gebäude für die nächsten tage in
deutschland angeordnet und er hat
bekannt gegeben dass heute abend eine
konferenz mit seinen länder und
innenminister kollegen stattfindet auf
der vor allem darüber beraten wird wie
in den kommenden tagen öffentliche
veranstaltungen und insgesamt die
sicherheit höher geschraubt werden kann
aber ich denke da wird auch über
politische mögliche konsequenzen aus
diesem schrecklichen anschlag hier in
hanau gesprochen werden
vielen dank für ihre information peter
wagner in hannover so weit der aktuelle
stand zu dem anschlag in hanau um 17 uhr
melden wir uns mit der nächsten heute
sendung mehr dazu auch in einem zdf
spezial direkt nach der 19 uhr heute
nachrichten alle entwicklungen zu hanau
können sie auch online verfolgen in
einem live blog unter heute.de auf
wiedersehen